hey everyone at seven Carmichael we are
just about to start the next webinar and
I'm here live with Jason fonseka from
rice online.com and I wanted to take the
quick opportunity to introduce you guys
to him now I've met Jason through my
website was part of my forms an
entrepreneur community online and he was
so super helpful to everybody who was in
the forums giving tons of advice just
being a force of good for entrepreneurs
on the site and he's based in my
hometown of Toronto and I thought one
day I had a Thursday night free and i
said i want to know this guy jason a
little bit better so I fired off an
email to Jason what he up to tonight you
wanna grab some drinks and he said sure
and so we met up and I thought we talked
for maybe like an hour an hour and a
half and it turned into like four or
five hour extravaganza and I think we
may have gotten kicked out of the place
and we talked about his business my
business and just loads of fun tons of
information and one of the things that I
really learned from Jason at that point
was he ports of branding and we talked
about how you have to have a strong
message and it has to be communicated
across all your marketing material and
from there i reworked my website and put
new pictures up we change my slogan I
changed my font and that was all thanks
to that one discussion we had over
wouldn't we drink avocado avocado
avocado milkshake yeah and shines out
that was awesome and so I wanted to
introduce you guys quickly to Jason
before we start the webinar here today
and Jason maybe just share some of your
advice on branding some quick tips where
you see entrepreneurs making mistakes
and how they can do better love to man
i'm super happy to be here thanks for
the invitation and okay let's get right
to it um branding is a huge subject that
you talk about it forever it's a key or
a core to someone success in anything
really not just business and right off
the top one of the most important things
is don't be ugly um it sounds simple but
there's a lot
involve doing this means attention to
detail this means hiring people do a
good job at creating your materials um
if you're gonna make a video get a video
got involved if you're going to make a
website get a website got involved and
make sure that the quality control and
standards dot your i's cross your T's
make sure every pixel is perfect um some
people are really like anal and they
have a good time with this like they
really their brand comes across really
well Steve Jobs famous for you would not
release anything from Apple until it was
a hundred percent perfect this guy's
like that he doesn't do anything either
yeah my grooming you cut a pixel on my
site I'm notable for effort it's been
bothering me nothing really like I can't
why don't you know priorities are
priorities you you can't remember guys
across his teeth crossing to you when
there's fires going out of whatever
result step by step but um but yeah the
second thing um consistency you
mentioned it briefly when you were
introducing have everything consistent
across all channels it's again it's a
simple word but it expands into a huge
topic this means that the stuff you
speak about on camera like it needs to
all relate to your brand um jay-z is a
rapper musician and everything he talks
about relates back to the music or the
culture or the hip hop or the whatever
he does even if he's talking about the
latest movie or the llama or whatever
he's always relating it somehow back to
his core his core message um if you have
a logo or a color scheme or a font like
you said get some consistency you picked
up on and you stick to it and hopefully
you've chosen the fun Wow and it
represents your brand while like if
you're you know a dark gothic tattoo
parlor you didn't pick you know Barney
cutesy font or whatever I like 10 font
size my site nowadays I need to be fixed
and then we ended it was easier fix yeah
but it took like it took expert
knowledge you just have to enough that
you got to talk to somebody or like
research training Google branding do
something too many small businesses skip
this and they don't have to because a
brand is a perception atop everybody
sees you
anna has one whether it's [ __ ] or
fantastic um and so you have one right
now and if you haven't looked into it at
all you're probably hurting yourself so
third thing this is the most important i
would say rest relax yes anything for
brain at cats come from the heart as a
vision um every human being on earth all
7 billion have these unique lives unique
experience they all grew up a different
way um again I guess on Eugene he's he's
been I love jay-z I so i'll use it was
an example but him and all the other
rappers like eminem they have totally
different backgrounds and life
experiences and they stay in four
different things she doesn't come out
and like cuss everywhere and be dark and
an ingredient have all kinds of like
horrible things going on it's not an
angry rapper or whatever but having an
egg's you talks about is like trailer
times and dark times and eight mile and
drug rehab and all this kind of stuff
and jay-z talks about like changing
changing culture and coming from like a
rough background rags to riches kind of
thing and he's always not inspiring
others so each of those people they're
in the same business we're in the same
industry but they stand for different
things that's human being and it's hard
to eight you can't make it up keep it
almost in for this one day you have to
have a life experience that says i scan
this yourself you help entrepreneurs and
11 top you're talking evaded no cry out
it's odd to be casual about it now to
quote see those it is people you help I
mean I'm an entrepreneur a bit and you
like no those aren't just people i
helped it's a way of life that's what I
stand for like right over that the best
thing I ever saw and I was a passive
show up in your brain yeah and it does
and same goes for all the audience
everybody works you can do right now you
right there in your seat you stand for
something you have a life experience and
stuff you care about and most people
repress it and hide it because they
don't want to talk about it some people
are really sex positive and they don't
want to come out and say that some
people want to you know talk about race
but they don't say that some of you want
to really help entrepreneurs but you
know if you never said that you wouldn't
be where you wanted it but you stood up
for it and sing same for for anybody try
to expand their brain so that's my three
tips there you go at three
tears from Jason fonseka you can check
them out at rise online com we're gonna
grab some pizza and then start the
webinar you guys know the drill you like
the video please give it a thumbs up and
if you have any comments or questions
for me or Jason this time we're both
gonna be checking the comment feed so
please leave a comment even just to say
hey good job guys enjoy the pizza and
we'll see you guys soon all right Cheers
thanks guys